hello everyone i'm alana and welcome to
my channel where today i wanted to make
a video about
the current situation that i am in um
where
i could be stuck in australia and i
don't actually know if i am yet i just
sort of have to wait
to find out if i'm stuck uh i wanted to
make this video
mostly to help other australian citizens
who might have to go through this whole
process
similar to how i documented the
quarantine
process for entering the country during
the pandemic
um but also just for anyone else who
might find this kind of situation
interesting because
it is very bizarre we're living in a
pretty unique circumstance so
why not talk about it so for the basics
for anyone who doesn't know
um if you're an australian citizen you
are allowed to enter
australia they aren't able to buy you
that would be like on an international
scale extremely illegal to stop letting
citizens in
permanently to the country that they
belong in or the only one that they
legally have right to permanently exist
in
um so i was able to get here it was very
expensive um
yeah an extremely prohibitively
expensive process that i'm sure
can make it really difficult for a lot
of people to come home a lot of flights
are getting cancelled things get pushed
um but entering really the most
difficult part was really just that it
required the two-week hotel quarantine
which cost me
three thousand dollars and you have to
be in a hotel
not able to leave or i wasn't able to
leave at all never once left the hotel
room for
14 days straight um and now i've been
out for
two months i think yeah
no month and a half to spend time with
my family which has been absolutely
wonderful
so the leaving part of the process if
you are
an australian citizen right now the
blanket rule is that you cannot leave
australia
while clovert is in place they are not
letting any aussies leave under any
circumstances really
um unless you get approved for an
exemption and there are a bunch of ways
to
get approved but the whole situation
basically means that my family
is not able to come visit me right now i
was able to come visit them when i
returned to la
where i live i don't even have to
quarantine on the way back
um two countries handling this whole
situation
very differently so the exemption
process
kind of depends on your reason for
leaving uh
and there are there are a number of them
obviously the one that pertains to me is
that
i do not ordinarily live in
australia um there is a kind of
complicated addition to that if you
don't live
in australia but you are an australian
citizen in some cases you don't have to
apply for an exemption
but because i live in the us on an 0-1
visa
technically according to
the border um i don't actually live in
the u.s
on paper this is a conversation i've had
with people like on twitter who don't
understand the american
um sort of immigration system not that
i'm an immigrant but
because i'm on a visa i'm not an
immigrant uh i do not
live in the u.s even though i have an
apartment there and i paid rent there
for six full years and i would tell you
oh i live in la
legally i do not i even had someone
uh at the u.s border correct me on it
they said why are you coming into the
country and i said oh i live here
and they corrected me and said no you
work here
because of the terms of a visa basically
you have a permit to work
in the u.s or at least i have a permit
to work in the u.s i do not actually
have a permit to
live in the us and they count these as
two different things
if i were on a green card or if i were
an american citizen then i wouldn't have
to worry about the exemption at all but
because i am on a working visa that is
very specific to work
um this is why i can't leave la uh
people are like why don't you just move
somewhere cheaper i don't have that kind
of freedom my visa is tied to my job
my job is tied to la uh i don't live
in the country i do not have any freedom
there are a lot of restrictions
on a lot of different things it's very
stressful living in a country on a visa
but in any case that meant that um
i did have to apply for the exemption
because i don't technically live
overseas i just work overseas um
so i had to fill out
a form provide a bunch of documentation
i provided
tax returns that proved my address i
provided my
visa which shows that i'm in the us for
a long period of time
um and i showed oh no sorry i actually
filled out
a statutory declaration form uh that i
had to have signed
by someone who is in a certain
profession so i had it signed by a
dentist
basically saying that i am telling the
truth that i am leaving australia and
that i don't intend to come back any
time
soon which is really the caveat they
want to make sure that you aren't just
jumping between
countries for fun i have to just verify
i am not
planning to return to australia for the
rest of the year um which i can't see
myself doing
unless there were some maybe potentially
very extreme circumstance like a family
member dying or something like that
otherwise i don't want to go through
that lockdown process again
it was so bad for me health-wise my
asthma was just terrible
so i will avoid coming back to australia
while the pandemic is happening
basically so i had that signed and then
i submitted it all online
um my exemption has now been approved
though there were some hiccups
initially um which i don't feel like is
beneficial to anyone to get into but
yes so i i have been approved to leave
the country
at this point i am allowed to get on a
plane
um outside of that the parts that are
complicated
um this is not complicated but an
important note for anyone trying to do
this i have to get a covered test 72
hours before my international flight so
i have to get a covered test
um to make sure that i'm actually
allowed to get on the plane i probably
need to show a negative result to board
the plane
the issue for me is
the pandemic's timing just really doing
just doing whatever it wants as it turns
out
uh i
have to because there are no direct
flights from queensland
or brisbane which is the airport that i
would be flying from
it's where most of my family is there
are no direct flights from brisbane
to la i'm not even sure if there are any
direct flights from brisbane to the us
in general i don't believe there are
i have to fly through sydney so in order
to get home
i have to go from brisbane to sydney to
la
and on paper that seems fine who cares
whatever
but my flight from
la sorry from sydney to la is pretty
early the one that's currently
booked it's pretty early in the morning
so
because so many flights are being
delayed or cancelled
um between brisbane and sydney recently
it was
uh the entire day they canceled every
single flight just
like that every single brisbane sydney
flight was cancelled blanket
the whole day um and that could happen
to me
if i'm to get the earliest morning
flight which again even because of
covert there are less options for that
available um the earlier earliest ones
aren't as early as they used to be by
any means and there aren't as many
flights
not the same amount of frequency um if
that
flight were to get cancelled or even be
delayed slightly i would probably miss
the international connection
it's up in the air whether that will
happen or not um
i kind of don't know the reason to not
or the reason to do that let me paint
that differently
my flight is currently booked for me to
fly to sydney
the night before uh so i would get in
sydney a day before
brisbane a sydney flight that day arrive
in sydney stay overnight in sydney and
then get
the flight out from sydney to la the
issue with that
is that sydney is currently in lockdown
in australia um
there are a number of covered cases in
sydney right now
and the airport is not out of the
lockdown zone i don't believe or at
least it's not very far
out um there are there are
sections the way that they handle these
things or like certain suburbs kind of
get locked down
and what lockdown means in australia we
did have a lockdown here where i am
last week for three days um basically is
stayed home everybody stays at home um a
lot of places are still open
uh like my local coffee shop was still
open but everyone has to wear a mask
um it doesn't feel quite as strict as it
felt in the us
um the rules probably are stricter but i
would say on paper
because there are so few covert cases i
think
it's just not as harrowing probably
so yeah you can get locked down for a
certain amount of time sydney is
currently in lockdown
if i get my brisbane to sydney flight
and lockdown is still happening i would
have to stay
in sydney potentially for even two weeks
they wouldn't let me leave sydney
if you enter the lockdown zone you can't
leave the lockdown zone
so if i'm to go to sydney and i'm going
to
stay overnight in a hotel and even even
if it's like say
in that five hour chunk of time before
midnight or whatever or
i don't even know if it matters to that
extent if at any point
during me being in sydney to get on a
flight the next morning
there is lockdown maybe if lockdown
lifts and i fly there and lockdown is
reinstated
i can't leave city i cannot go to the
airport i cannot go to la
so i run the risk of going to sydney and
then being stuck in sydney
i wouldn't be able to fly back to
brisbane i would just be stuck
in sydney um and this is basically my
issue there is currently a lockdown in
sydney
my intended flight is quite soon
and if the lockdown persists
i either well
truthfully what i have to do is get that
morning flight and hope that it doesn't
get delayed
or cancelled so that i don't miss my
international flight because then i
could end up in the same boat
i feel like that's what i'm going to
have to do and i should find out at the
airport if it's delayed or cancelled
right and if that happens
i just have to pull out of the whole
thing and try again
in a week um if lockdown is lifted
then in theory i would do my overnight
in sydney and just pray
that lockdown doesn't get reinstated in
the small period of time while i'm there
because then again i can't leave and i
can't even be with family
it is so much messier
than i would have thought um but i also
understand why you know all these
restrictions are in place to keep
australians safe that's the purpose of
it
that's the reason that i haven't had to
worry about my family while i've been
living in the u.s
the whole time the pandemic's happening
i haven't been worried about my very old
grandma she's like 95.
i haven't been worried about my dad who
has had lung issues and
and my stepdad who has cancer um that
i've not been
super concerned about my family is
because of this stuff but
man does it make leaving complicated i
really am in the position of
lockdown could get lifted i could be
allowed to go to sydney and stay in a
hotel
i even looked into seeing if i could
stay in sydney overnight but because of
covered sorry in the airport overnight
like maybe i could pay
at an extra bunch of money to go into
one of like the lounges to stay
overnight um
but they all close i don't know if they
always all closed but everything is
certainly
closing now i do not have the option to
stay in the airport overnight um
unfortunately so i'm really just at the
mercy
of the virus right now um
of course this is not a huge deal in the
grand scheme of things you know i'm very
happy to be home
i'm uh still getting my work done i've
kept my workplace very up to date um
because of course they're us based on
all of this and
i'm just trying to kind of over inform
them on the situation so they understand
but
uh it hasn't aside from a few internet
issues really just one day
um it hasn't actually negatively
impacted work at all so that part is
fine
um yeah this video isn't intended for me
to be complaining at all
um just kind of explaining the
complexity of a unique
situation really and yeah i don't uh
i don't know what's gonna happen my
flight back to the u.s is supposed to be
quite
soon and right now
i gotta fly out of brisbane in that
morning
and hope that things don't get delayed
and that i don't miss the entire trip
but
we'll see i feel like it's pretty likely
that i will be okay
to do that that i will get back to la um
if not it'll probably be in that same
week that i'm supposed to fly i'm
thinking but
yeah really really up in the air right
now and that's just me doing my best job
to explain the situation of course
um i talked to a flight attendant about
this sorry flight agent i intentionally
hired a flight agent for this whole trip
because it's very complicated to make
sure that i'm talking to someone who's
very on top of it and understands things
that i don't so i'm not just like
dealing with this chaos by myself um and
she's been super helpful and
understanding and very
communicative with me so i would
definitely recommend anyone who's
looking to do this kind of thing
get a flight agent um it is so nice to
have somebody that you can ask all these
questions to and who can tell you why
you can't do this and why you shouldn't
do this flight and why you should do
this flight because otherwise
it's just like looking at a bunch of
information and being like [ __ ]
um but that's the reality of the
situation i'm in
not quite as scary as the time that i
had my
passport confiscated by the us embassy
in japan and only got it back
on the morning of my flight back that
was that was a whole
stressful nightmare but um you know
right now
the two outcomes are that i go back to
la
and the weather is beautiful and i get
to see all my friends which i'm looking
forward to
um or i get to stay here with my family
where it is a little bit colder
but uh still pretty beautiful and i get
to be with my family
so you know both outcomes are frankly
pretty great
i'm in a good spot regardless but just
kind of wanted to talk about
the situation um and also to update
everyone on the channel about
content obviously i've not been
uploading anywhere near as much as
normal since i've been
with my family just because i am
prioritizing spending time with them
it's very important to me so i've
generally been doing
one video a week and the podcast that we
have missed a couple episodes the
podcast
um and i've only streamed twice the
whole time
uh on twitch um so apologies for all of
that
but as i said when i streamed earlier
today actually i
can't tell you that i'm sorry i can tell
you that i'm acknowledging that i'm
making a lot less content
um than i normally would right now but
yeah i feel like it's for a very good
reason i just want to spend time with my
family i don't want to be in front of a
computer
i really am missing playing video games
obviously got the wii u over here
ps5 right here but i'm barely touching
video games right now and that's very
weird for me i'm like anxious about it
playing a lot of oculus and playing um
keep talking and nobody explodes and
um beat saber and stuff like that with
my mum which has been super fun but
in general very weird so yes
ultimately i don't know when i'm getting
back to the us i don't know what content
will go back to normal i will keep you
all updated
um hopefully the situation doesn't get
too much more complicated and for anyone
looking to do the same kind of traveling
as said on my previous videos
feel free to ask me any questions i am
happy to help because i know this stuff
is really difficult so
any way that i can help i will and
oh my god i think i'm going to publish
this video without any edits
that never happens wow magic
it's probably really rambly but you get
the idea
alrighty everyone thank you guys for
watching i will see you